[Music]
in an attempt to curb gentrification
the city of chicago recently passed a
law making it harder
to convert to flat apartments
incidentally
too flat is also the technical term for
a white woman's butt
no you know as much as i think that's a
funny joke
i feel like that punchline is well-worn
territory
and i'm ashamed i would like to vow
to never make a joke like that again you
know
the whole white lady flat butt thing is
a well i go to a lot
and i'm starting to feel like it's lazy
and
it may even be hurtful so i'd like to
give it up
in style no
i'm never gonna joke never ever gonna
joke about flat butts again
it's rude it's crass to talk about your
flat ass i'm bout to be a better friend
no i'm never gonna say
your butt's very musical somehow it's
flat and sharp at the same time
i'm growing i'm evolving and i don't
want to say things that make people feel
bad
like when my white women friends come
over i'm no longer gonna say
thank you for what for somehow sitting
on the couch
without leaving an indentation in the
cushions good
you shouldn't say that and i'll
definitely make sure not to say
when god made you baby he really broke
the mold well that's a nice thing to say
well he didn't really break the mold as
much as he ripped it up
the mold was a piece of paper
[Music]
no i'm never gonna joke never
ever gonna joke about flat butts again
it's rude it's crass to talk about your
flat ass i found to be a better friend
no i'm never gonna say
hey what's this an earring no it's a
swing for a white woman
again
look the truth is i've never thought my
butt was big enough and
it makes me sad but when i think about
the hilarious stereotype of flat bootied
white women
it makes me smile but i don't want you
to develop a complex even if it helps me
with mine
so i'm done this time
i swear i keep change
no i'm never gonna joke never even gonna
joke about flat butts again
it's rude it's crass to talk about your
flat ass i vowed to be a better friend
no i'm never gonna say
must be cool to be able to wear your
pants backwards and forwards
again
amber you are the worst
[Music]
[Applause]
you